what is the cost of political chaos five
prime ministers in six years an endless
parade of leadership contests the pace
of events in Westminster has been
Relentless constant campaigning is
pricey who's footing the bills this week
Sky News opened the Westminster account
so everyone can find out
17.2 million pounds that's the amount
that's gone to MP's in donations and
Gifts in this Parliament that means it's
since December 2019 and that's money
that doesn't go into MP's pocket that
helps them and their constituency
campaigns and here we are for the first
time we can see the 20 MPS with the most
donations in this Parliament and so many
of them are current or former Party
leaders or contenders 12 still in the
comments because of the years of
political upheaval now the man at the
top fighting a leadership contest back
in 2020 and since then Doing Hard yards
of opposition these are the labor
leaders top datas note the top spots
aren't unions but wealthy businessmen
that's very different to his predecessor
now that's the top ten but the 11th is
worth a special mention that is
ecotricity the green Energy company run
by Mogul Dale Vince who has given 20 000
pounds to kirst armor and 360
000 pounds to the labor party in this
Parliament one of the 10 biggest donors
to the party luckily for us Del Vince is
happy to be transparent about the other
causes he supports
just stop oil
causing chaos let's stand together as we
Face broken politics dividing opinion
group's campaign of disruption has
brought motorways to a standstill and
made a target of prized artworks
condemned by kirstama in an LBC
interview I think they're wrong I think
their action is wrong I think it's
arrogant of those gluing themselves to
the road to think they're the only
people that have got the answer this
they haven't got the answer and I don't
know how they can look in the eye of the
families who've got someone in the back
of an ambulance they certainly wouldn't
be able to look me in the eye not
holding back but Sky News can reveal
that one of his party's biggest donors
is also a key just stop oil backer Dale
Vince is not hiding from scrutiny about
who he funds people like Extinction
Rebellion I gave them some money help
them get started just our boil same
thing we're talking tens of thousands
probably do you think waiters will take
a view on the fact that the labor party
is taking money from the person who
helped start them we reach a point when
um taking to the streets is all we've
really got you know most people have no
power to change what's happening and we
can see the direction of travel is a
disastrous one and so I understand why
organizations like that do the things
that they do they're a conflict there
care starmer wants to change things
through political means to The Ballot
Box and through Parliament and there you
are saying that all you've got left is
taking to the street those two things
are incompatible yeah we've had 12 years
of a Tory government haven't we and I
think that that leaves people feeling
frustrated about direction of travel in
the event that labor got into power
would you encourage just stop oil to
stop their activities I got a feeling
that well I know if labor get into Power
I'm sure there will be a ban on new
licenses in the North Sea and that's the
single ask of just stop oil
so I think they will not exist anymore
it's the person who for now matters the
most prime minister Rishi sunak who's
half a million pound fund was raised
over last summer in his failed
leadership bid here you can see the big
money flowing into his coffers from
donors who load the Alternatives top
Dana Chris Ray said he was horrified by
Liz truss's policies Mick Davis said
only the deluded thought Boris Johnson
was the answer another 20 000 came from
someone just below this list Elena
shawcross she's now head of policy in
number 10. now a former labor leader
here's top donor well the clues in the
name JBC defense are one of the biggest
donors to individuals in this Parliament
and they give to one man Jeremy Bernard
Corbin that's all money crowdfunded
after a liable legal fight settled out
of court
also another big donor an unfamiliar
company former lib Dem leader receiving
over a hundred and fifty thousand Pounds
into Nations across this Parliament from
faith in public Limited
and it turns out a company set up by Mr
farron himself you can change Britain's
future thank you
lib Dem leader in the aftermath of
brexit he struggled during the 2017
election campaign when facing a barrage
of questions about his faith now on the
back benches open about his beliefs who
is ultimately behind the donations he
gets less clear to the public so a
company that was set up by an MP that in
this Parliament has given over a hundred
and fifty thousand pounds to that MP
he's an unusual Arrangement and under
the system that we have we can't trace
where the money originally comes from
now that company is behind me it's faith
in public limited and we know that it
provides Staffing and PR advice for Tim
Baron resources that frankly not every
MP has access to but we can't trace
where the money's from in the public
register so we had to do some digging
after getting no response from our
questions to his office I called Tim
fahren myself he said it wasn't his
intention to conceal his backers and
handed us a list of donors to Faith in
public in this Parliament revealed here
for the first time the biggest the solar
trust donated 90 000 pounds it describes
itself as conservative Evangelical in
its theology the cross trust has given
thirty thousand pounds it says it offers
grants to deserving young people a step
forward but this Arrangement means those
names would never appear in the
Westminster accounts
some things are transparency tool can't
show you but so much that it can
tomorrow the murky world of lobbying
[Music]